sanctimonious Democrat Al Franken has
been not only accused of groping a news
anchor during a USO tour while she slept
he even posed for a photograph doing it
what a smart guy if we have to lose the
Alabama Senate race we can at least take
that clown down with us white
nationalist Richard Spencer loses his
verified status as Twitter infringes on
his constitutional right to a blue check
mark and Charles Manson lies on his
deathbed 46 years after he was sentenced
to death for the murder of 11 people
phileas talks bradley Devlin and Alicia
Kraus joined the panel of deplorable
--zz to discuss best of all the great
Eric Metaxas comes on the show to defend
martin luther's honor against my pope
insults and to discuss his new book
Martin Luther the man who rediscovered
God and changed the world finally all of
your most pressing questions and your
answered and your life has changed in
the mailbag I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael nul show
[Music]
there is so much news to get to today
and so much delight that we can take if
Al Franken getting caught up in this
sexual harassment witch-hunt by the way
when I say it's a witch-hunt it is we're
clearly in a witch-hunt mindset but
there are witches that's the other
aspect of this do
there are Weinstein's out there so we're
in a witch-hunt but there are witches
here we have a lot to get to but listen
I caught a lot of flack for my Martin
Luther episode people thought that I was
a little harsh on the corpulent German
heretic they they felt that I was overly
Pope ish and a little leaning in toward
Rome so to rectify this I brought on the
great Eric Metaxas he was kind enough to
do an interview we pre-recorded it so it
could go a little bit longer and
providentially it was on Martin Luther's
birthday actually November 10th that we
recorded it he's going to talk about his
new book and defend Martin Luther
against my Pope is on slot now I have
the great pleasure of being joined by
someone that I'm a big fan of both for
his radio show and for his writing Eric
Metaxas host of the Eric Metaxas show
and author of the new book Martin Luther
the man who rediscovered God and changed
the world
now Eric I do not share your admiration
of the corpulent German exactly but I
did really enjoy the book I thought the
narrative is very compelling very
readable and I learned so much about
Martin Luther that I didn't know before
and more importantly I unlearned so many
things about Martin Luther that I did
know it's like what Ronald Reagan used
to say it's not that our liberal friends
are ignorant they just know so much that
isn't so that basically was my view of
Luther and your book corrected that a
lot so yeah what made you write it most
of what we know about him is a myth or a
legend or at least a half truth which is
to say a lie I didn't go into this book
I don't go into any of my books knowing
what I want to write I just go in with a
healthy level of ignorance and curiosity
and honesty and I say I'm just gonna
write what I find but what I found about
Luther was that much of what is said
about him over and over and over is just
not true the first thing is everybody
says he was raised in a very poor family
that his father was a poor minor he
often said kinda like politicians sort
of furnish their street cred you know
their home
bona fides he says that my father was a
humble miner that's true and it's not
true his father was a successful
businessman in the mining business
he was socially upwardly mobile which is
an extraordinary thing in the 1480s that
there was enough of a free market that
somebody could be not wealthy but could
get wealthy or work hard and that there
was enough of a opportunity let's say so
the father borrowed it seems a lot of
money from the mother's family and
started this huge business and I had to
work very hard to justify the loan to
get it you know to work out so these
were hard workers but the more we know
about Luther there's a bunch of things
in the book that are brand-new I talked
about a couple of archaeological things
that was done 2003 2008 where they
discovered that the actual house that
Luther was born in is three times as
large as they've been saying for five
years so it's kind of crazy and then
they found a lot of garbage trash and
they could think through it and they
they discovered real evidence that these
were people of some means he was not
raised in under no circumstance it's a
nice toys you read the book thank you
I really enjoyed the book I read it over
a cigar because the body is a temple and
the temple needs incense the the claim
that comes later on in the book that you
point out which is probably the essence
of the Protestant revolution and it's
what Hamlet talks about is that Luther
cracked the cover of objective truth
cracked the authority and the the
ownership of objective truths and we've
seen a lot of varied consequences from
that on the one hand we have political
freedom and the nation-states and
liberal democracy on the other hand you
and I both attended a former university
called Yale and there are people run
wreaking havoc over there because they
changed their name because he was a
slave holder he was a slave trader they
have to change it to I don't know mr.
Rogers University this man ever to
graduate from
at least previous centuries and I think
that they should change the name but yes
the world the door that Luther opened we
all know led to tremendous things and to
terrible things that's part of the price
of freedom right in other words when you
say to people you are free you are free
to say and believe stupid things or the
to saying believes wonderful things
that's freedom in America we protect
people who say things we disagree with
that's at the essence of freedom you
know and I know that it feel more
complicated than that I wrote a whole
book called if you can keep it by book
before this where I go into how if you
don't have a virtuous populace if faith
is not at the heart of the culture
self-government doesn't work people will
destroy themselves as has happened many
times in the past free market will not
give us everything we're looking for
these things need to have people running
them in such a way that they're going to
give us what we watched right so what
Luther enabled I think but the great
things but it also led to many terrible
things I'll be the first to say it and
I'd love the point about mass
communication I loved when you're
writing about how Luther himself didn't
intend for his 95 theses to spread as
quickly as they did is ubiquitously as
they did almost like a facebook debate
you know it gets out of hand and
everybody sees it and he said he had
some doubts about them he might have
written it differently how instrumental
were two things to the spread of those
theses the sale of indulgences my only
quibble with your book by the way is I
felt you were a little harsh on Pope
Sixtus the fourth I felt that he but you
know every people are a little harsh on
Sixtus and and they the confusion over
the sale of indulgences married to this
printing press where people on the other
side of the world end up reading
Luther's thesis and say Oh Martin good
job pal I didn't I didn't know you read
it the channels of communication
effectively don't exist the cultural
elites which in those days were a church
and the state
please control and if you try to get a
message to somebody else you can't
there's just no ability to do that
suddenly somebody invents the printing
press and you can write something and
whether you like it or not someone else
to copy it and print it and distribute
it very cheaply and then people who get
it can reprint it and distribute it and
it goes on and on it's no different than
you know forwarding something hitting
reply all and it goes to everybody you
think uh-oh
what just happened that wasn't possible
10 years ago or 20 years ago but
suddenly everybody knows and there's no
way to get the horse back in the barn
Luther's feces I mean one of the hugest
misconceptions in the story of Luther
which you know it's such a good story
people want to believe it but they have
this idea that in 1517 this young man
wanted to stick his finger in the Pope's
eye and post this incendiary document in
the most incendiary place imaginable hey
how about the church door and then you
find out no no no not that we're looking
at it you know from a different
perspective what happened at the time
was a humble monk who loved his church
and loved his poll wanted to bring
attention to something that he thought
was dragging the church's name through
the mud and he did this for the church
for the honor of the church he said this
is not right that we have allowed the
practice of indulgences to get out of
hand so that people come into my
confessional and throwing this piece of
paper in front of me saying hey Padre Oh
what can I get for this you know a lot
of penance free card right that's what
it is so Luther saw as a brilliant
theologian and as a very serious priest
and monk he said this is bad for the
faithful the souls of my flock are in
danger and so he says we need to have an
academic debate a proper academic debate
but everybody was having academic it's
what you did when there was you know
trouble you said let's discuss it so he
writes in lad he ninety five points
some of them slightly provocative
because you wanted to provoke a good
academic debate and he posts it on the
local bulletin board which is the church
door but it but it says if so you
picture him with a hammer and nails
thundering against the paper
so you know and that's completely wrong
data ran with the ology right - well
picture him with a pushpin down by the
laundry room putting it on the bulletin
board next to the thing with the missing
cat and the guitar lessons I mean
basically that's what he did was quietly
somehow it just spread and spread and it
got way out of hand he never intended it
cause trouble that's the fact
and speaking of his deference to the
Pope and not trying to do you know poke
a nail into his eye there's the the most
heartbreaking moment of the story is
that he writes the letter to the Pope he
writes a letter to Leo the tenth I
believe and it never is sent let's see
this is the thing you start I mean I
hope people will read the book because
it's startling and stunning when you see
what actually happened it's not it's the
way real life works and young little
thing happens stupid people
misunderstand things good people
misunderstand things
milt it's who is this papal Leggett sent
to kind of deal with Luther made some
terrible mistakes and a couple of other
people involved made some terrible
mistakes he kind of kept thinking if I
could deal directly with the Pope surely
he has to see what I'm saying is correct
I'm not trying to up end Catholic
doctrine am i his point is that the the
Pope the the Christian doctrine church
doctrine on indulgences is that you know
that remits penance and temporal
punishment for sin and while the Pope
doesn't have jurisdiction over souls in
purgatory he can intercede on your
behalf he can ask really nicely for
those souls to have less punishment and
then you'll get guys like Tetzel down at
the ground who are Hawking when the coin
rings then a soul out of purgatory
Springs so so much seems to be Luther
wanting to reach the Pope wanting to go
directly to the the Vicar of Christ on
earth the bark of Peter I mean look it's
so different than in a prop that a
president like Reagan not knowing what's
happening with his guys with iran-contra
right I mean you realize that it's very
complicated so he's on the hook
ultimately but there are people that he
has trusted and obviously people like
Tetzel were very fast and loose and
corruption one moment that struck me is
when Luther had not talked to his father
for a while because his father wanted to
become a lawyer
so he's this genius he's clearly a
prodigy just as he's about to become a
lawyer he doesn't want to become a
lawyer he's struck down there's this
moment this vision this thunderbolt and
right eventually they reconcile and
Luther's father says God grant that that
was not an apparition of the devil that
for that convinced you you know to go
and enter into the monastery what are
the odds that it was an apparition of
the devil five hundred years later the
fact is it could have been but it
doesn't matter because we serve a God
who is able to braid plans B C and D
back into plan a
Luther his heart was in the right place
and you know the Bible says God looks on
the heart this was a man who wanted what
God wanted and so sometimes we struggle
to figure out what is it that God what
is God like when he did this initially
his whole view of God was wrong
he had a view of God as a nasty judge
who was just slathering ruling to throw
people into hell if you have that view
of God you're gonna act accordingly
Luther thought the only thing I can do
to cover my rear end is to go into the
monastery I'm not gonna risk eternal
hell for a good luck career so he goes
to the monastery really you know to
cover his rear end and when he gets
there he tries as hard as anyone to pray
his way into the peace of God and to in
effect earn his way he could this is
what happens is that he has this sense
that I've got to do this and this and
this this I've got to jump through these
hoops and you feel like you're
performing and you're failing and what
kind of a God would put you through that
hell so you begin to resent God and hate
God he's reading the Bible reading the
Bible of course famously at some point
he discovers this idea that we are saved
by faith the righteousness of God is
given to us
it's not something that God uses to beat
us into hell he gives it to us as a free
gift so it turns his world upside down
and right around the same time was when
he decided
to post the bbc's on indulgences and so
it all kind of exploded their app you
the portrait you paint as you've just
described is of a guy who is an
obsessive he's a neurotic he is
constantly worrying himself to death he
seems to have a great fear of death he's
so gaunt and thin not like that portrait
that we imagined of him and then later
on he becomes this Gary Ellis fat German
fellow and he's constantly troubled by
intestinal pains a priest friend of mine
because of the word in cloaca or aux
cloaca the that it's it is suggestion
that he had his epiphany about Romans
while sitting on the commode and my
priest right and wondered what torrent
of commentary he could have unleashed on
the world with the modern colonic
irrigation that is neither here nor
there
of course I make fun of the freedom
that's you know that's that's what are
these Freudian theories in that I mean
there was a guy named Eric Erickson who
wrote a book about Luthor called young
man Luthor and if you want to talk about
a mid-century horror of a cliche 40 and
that's 350 pages of Freudian nonsense
really giving it Luthor no real credit
for being a person he's irrational in it
acts of urges and constipation and
libido and hey that's what makes the
world go round but in 1958 it was
difficult to argue against it so so yeah
people really misunderstand Luthor in
that way too they said his father was
really cruel and he was rebelling
against his father and there was this
oedipal spasm against his father and the
father god that made him do everything
he did it's completely ridiculous and
again the least you can do in a
biography and I hope I do in my book is
simply tell the facts and a story
emerges from the facts at least if you
have enough facts and at this point we
can say we do you certainly achieve it
in the book it's really really good I
highly recommend it even as a very Pope
ish fellow and traditionalist
conservative I really really enjoyed it
I recommend
everybody go out and read it it's Martin
Luther the man who rediscovered God and
changed the world we can quibble about
maybe the subtitle or 6 just the 4th or
what-have-you but a really good book
everyone should go ahead and read it and
of course listen to the Eric Metaxas
show it's a great show and Eric thanks
for being here and we definitely want to
have you back as soon as possible
Michael oh is my joy thank you so much
did I defend Sixtus enough I felt I
didn't sufficiently defend my it was too
much well we can all argue about that I
guess ok that was really great really
love Eric Metaxas I'd like to show a lot
and his writings so now I'm moving on to
his Bonhoeffer book and regardless of
him not really convincing me because I
like Martin Luther I still enjoyed the
the book and you should all go out and
read it so before we get to we have an
excellent panel today we have Bradley
Devlin we have flex talks we have Alicia
crass an excellent panel so much to talk
about but first capitalism we have to
get into a little capitalism we want to
thank the people who helped us keep our
lights on who keep Kofi Fay in my
tumbler and that is helix sleep today
now I have some personal experience with
this I've moved around a bit you know
moved from college to New York New York
to LA I've had I think three mattresses
in that time every time you go to buy a
mattress it is it is the worst
experience somehow it's always worse
than the last time it's very expensive
it's confusing you can't really compare
because they change the names of all the
mattresses so I've had decent mattresses
I've had terrible ones helix sleep is
revolutionising all of this the return
of online mattress retailers popping up
these days that's because going to the
store is just awful you know we're
Millennials we want it to come to us and
for it to be relatively inexpensive so
all of these online retailers they have
a one-size-fits-all solution to better
sleep well guess what buddy one size
doesn't fit all I have learned that I've
had some back problems in my life and
helix sleep offers something that
doesn't exist anywhere else
it's a mattress personalized to your
custom preferences that will not set you
back thousands of dollars I don't need
to write another blank book in order to
afford a helix mattress if you go to
helix sleep comm slash knowles that's
Kayano wles like Beyonce you can take
their simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz I get bored with stuff online it's
very fast
don't worry about it they will build you
a custom mattress that will be the best
thing you've ever slept on for couples
they will even personalize each side of
the mattress so for me for instance I
like a nice hard mattress suites little
ELISA can feel a little pee underneath
15 layers of fluffy mattresses so
they'll personalize it for you and
everyone from GQ to Cosmo they're all
talking about helix once you try it you
will find out why your custom mattress
arrives direct to your door in a week
shipping is completely free how long do
you want to try it for a night two
nights forget that you get a hundred
nights if you don't love it they will
pick it up and refund you in full you
don't pay anything it's very fast it's
inexpensive it's really high quality
product geared to you what could be
better than that so go to helix sleep
comm slash Knowles Keo wles
right now and you will get $50 toward
your custom mattress just for our very
Kafei listeners this is a nice thing
they're offering us you'd be crazy to
pass it up
that is helix sleep comm / Knowles for
$50 off your order
helix sleep comm / Knowles maybe while
you're there you check out the helix
mattress mattress protector I'm from New
York where bed bugs just scurry over
every aspect of every wall and crevice
so get your mattress protector or the
helix foundation but go there right now
helix comm / Knowles panel thank you for
being here we have much to get to today
we have Al Franken getting a little
handsy with reporters and being
sanctimonious as ever we have Richard
Spencer being unverified and poor
Charlie Manson is on his deathbed
apparently so let's start with Al
Franken he is in hot water
he has been sanctimonious since the 90s
since he was Stuart Smalley on Saturday
and I live just liberal insufferable he
wrote that book lies and the lying Liars
who tell them lamb lamb lamb and so
anyway now that we have this sexual
assault craze that is sweeping the
nation coast to coast
he's being swept up in it too this is a
guy who is demagogued on Donald Trump
he's constantly berating Republicans and
now it turns out that in 2006 during a
USO tour he groped a reporter a news
anchor named
Leighann tweetIn in her sleep he also
said that they had to rehearse a bit for
the USO show he said we have to practice
the kiss this is a line that actors use
all the time they joke they say oh we
got to practice that kissing scene you
got a pract you know and it's a little
joke apparently he took it pretty far
and he said we got to practice that
kissing scene and he grabbed her and
forced his tongue down her throat and
she said she had to go wash her mouth
out to get the taste of Al Franken out
of her mouth I certainly can imagine why
she would do that so she wrote this
piece it's I've decided it's time to
tell my story Franken is getting totally
swept up in it I love it it's so much
fun
but Alesha to be fair we always try to
be fair Roche Foucault said that
hypocrisy is the tribute that Vice pays
to virtue
so should we hold Democrats in
particular to account on sexual
debauchery and assault because they're
always demagoguing the women's issue the
war on women or with is that not fair
should we hold them to the same
standards we old Republicans I would
personally I would hold them to the same
standards that I hold Republicans and
wear this a Republican senator main
reason I don't want Roy Moore to live by
the way he just had a crazy press
conference it was insane I miss it
during my show all the media's fault
it's all Mitch McConnell's fault because
well that's true but he also might have
done all that stuff so I'm gonna hold
out Franken to the same standard that I
hold Roy Moore this isn't alleged
groping as Politico said in a title and
a tweet earlier there's photographic
evidence of this I posed for the photos
he posed for the photo and we're now
finding out that the USO volunteer
photographer was indeed his brother so
apparently creep runs in the family
I've met Leanne before she's a lovely
woman she's done multiple USO tours she
used to come for free to the Sean
Hannity Oliver North freedom concerts
that raise money for Kay and my children
to go to college she's a wonderful human
being and I'm a fan of her as a person
and I'm sure that she like many women
that have been victims of this had to
consider you know what is this going to
do to my career what is this gonna do to
you know the situation at large if I
come out and share this story and it
looks as if there might be another woman
that has said publicly yes Al Franken
did do this to me too and my story will
be out soon and of course now reporters
are hounding down if there's any women
that he's treated this way since being a
sitting senator on Capitol Hill and I
got
say I'm shocked we didn't look for this
sooner the guy's been his whole career
in Hollywood and Washington DC with
Warren Michaels who went who is of
course the creator of SNL and when he
was asked about well how come you guys
didn't do a cold SNL open making fun of
Harvey Weinstein he said oh well you
know it's a New York thing
well Bill O'Reilly Sean Hannity Rudy
Giuliani also people that are all from
New York that Loren Michaels has been
totally okay with making fun of over the
years and it doesn't really surprise me
that Al Franken came from that boys club
of comedy in in liberal New York and and
this is this is exactly the point
because there have been plenty of sex
scandals to go around certainly at Fox
News or wherever but for the really
high-profile ones of people in office or
running as candidates they seem to have
been Democrats of late obviously Bill
Clinton is the sexual creep par
excellence
but there's Anthony Weiner we're seeing
this we're seeing al franken now the
list goes on Bradley I'm curious about
this on as a campus question because
with the sexual hysteria on campus now
that bogus statistic that one in four
women is raped or something like that
who are the people perpetrating this the
hookup culture is pretty weird you know
it's I'm not that old I was on campus
five years ago and there was just a ton
of sex capping all the time it's pretty
casual but who are the guys who are
really perpetrating the creepy stuff
here is it the conservative kids
buttoned up Brooks Brothers or is it the
lefties who are at a one corner of their
mouth spouting all of this feminist
hogwash and then when no one's looking
they're the ones perpetrating these
crimes yeah I completely agree with you
that that statistic is fairly bogus but
it's because we see a movement towards
sexual liberation on the left thinking
that women are the same as men that
women want it just as badly as men and
there's been several studies where
college-age men admit that they haven't
had consensual sex so what they say is
oh well I was with her all night and I
had sex with her and you know it just
that's just the way I operate and that's
the way she operates because the left
has been telling me that women are the
same as men and women wanted just as bad
but
just simply isn't true so we can't deny
women their own agency in their own
volition by forcing upon them belief
systems and values to fight the
patriarchy and I think that that is a
major pitfall for the left and why
you're seeing a movement back towards
conservatism right now it's a very very
liberal environment but I think you're
gonna start seeing social conservatives
come out of the woodwork with all these
negatives that are coming from this
leftist agenda a huge statistic is
300,000 abortions per year right that's
interesting because I was asking in
particular because my theory is that
feminists woke woke bro nice guys are
the creepiest dudes on the planet and I
would never let my my daughter or my
fiancee or my female friends alone we in
a room with them you know because
they're they say they're really nice oh
man I get your feelings you know and
then they just get really creepy and
weird oh yeah man I love feminism yeah
yeah yeah but what you're saying is this
the philosophy itself it's that
philosophy that says women and men have
entirely identical views of sex and
relationships to sex and just
unquenchable desires for sex and so if a
woman regrets an experience or a woman
is in a bad place and gets very drunk
and the man gets very drunk and there's
some regret or something then hey no
harm no foul you know we both made a
mistake or something when really that
isn't a traditional view and that that
isn't the case because men and women are
complementary and they're not identical
very good point flex you're right in
Hollywood you know for so long there has
been this double standard so Gloria
Steinem flax for Bill Clinton right Bill
Clinton is accused of sexual harassment
sexual assault on and on and she says
well he's good on abortion so we're
gonna stand by our guy the feminists
follow her is that we're seeing now
left-wing guys falling because of this
is that double standard cracking or once
this witch-hunt goes away is it going to
be right back in place I think the
double standard is cracking and hello
Michael Knowles thank you for having me
in to say man I loved your last video on
Ben Shapiro at the outside of UCLA
everyone if you're not watching flexes
videos go to flex talks on YouTube is a
real
ban it - the difference between the
protesters and the Shapiro audience
people is just tremendous it says a lot
about our country yeah a lot of Nazi go
home chance and I was like wow
but yeah the double standard is cracking
I really think it is because I think
right now we're dealing with a lot of
echo chambers so everyone's just seeing
what they agree with they're seeing
their values reaffirmed and it's tough
to get stories that actually break
through the echo chamber and our
bipartisan people that can agree on in a
bipartisan way so when they do and it's
like these you know sexual misconduct
cases even though they said allege
meanwhile he's like looking at the
camera and it was completely
premeditated but when these cases do
actually break the echo chambers I think
it raises the level of awareness so
going forward I think these cases of
sexual misconduct are gonna be you know
way less popular and well you know just
a way less in general and the whole
industry is gonna change but I think the
fact that we are seeing these cases come
forward and it does tend to be Democrats
and you know disgusting Hollywood I
think going forward it has to change and
I think it will well I hope it does I
don't know I'm a little less hopeful
than you are probably but that show that
it's worth that it is changing I mean
Hillary Clinton lost millennial women
because millennial women were children
during the age of Bill Clinton and then
now in the age of the Internet even if
they didn't vote for Donald Trump he's
bringing the accusers to the debate he's
bringing it up his surrogates bringing
it up was enough for a lot of millennial
women to go
yeah we're not okay with this we're not
going to go out and and go vote for a
woman that stayed married to a man that
had these accusations in his past and so
I I agree there I think that politically
this is maybe potentially an opportunity
for the Republicans to say hey guys
we're supposed to be the party of the
good guys if we call out our own creeps
the Democrats don't they have a history
of not doing it so come on over to the
right side yeah absolutely they wouldn't
just vote for her because she was a
woman and one thing when Trump decided
to bring those women to the debate all
of Clinton's accusers people said this
is awful this is tawdry no one cares
this is twenty years old why are you
rehashing this
he clearly sensed something about the
moment sexual harassment sexual assault
is in the air right now for many riously
the Access Hollywood tape came out
against him talking to Billy Bush and
it's just in there and bringing the
fight to them which we we have not done
for 20-30 years
bring bringing it to them on that is
really a really strong response and I'm
glad we're seeing it crack and I hope
that that double standard goes away okay
we have much more to get to we have to
talk about verification Richard Spencer
and Charlie Manson is dying but
unfortunately you can't see it plus the
mail bag by the way I'm going to answer
all of your questions in the mail bag
but unless you're a daily wire
subscriber you can't see it so go over
to daily wired.com right now what's the
pitch well you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you got the Ben Shapiro show
yeah yeah but this this I can't tell you
how many people Envy my vessel the
leftist tears tumblr because they're so
abundant right now the leftist tears are
pouring out everywhere every new Trump
tweet about CNN and the failing New York
Times and those basketball players who
then thanked him once they thanked him
they started gushing I could bear I had
all my breath and the only way to get
this is to subscribe right now as an
annual member ten bucks a year of I wish
ten dollars a month a hundred dollars a
year and you will get the leftist here's
tumbler the finest vessel for leftist
ears on planet earth and the entire
multiverse so go to daily wire.com we'll
be right back
[Music]
Richard Spencer has been unverified on
Twitter they did this to Miley innopolis
before they kicked him off
I think they kicked off Baked Alaska
who's a white nationalist guy you know
alright figure and Richard Spencer has
lost it now he is his constitutional
right to a blue checkmark is clearly
being infringed on Alicia I to play
devil's advocate here literally tells
advocate in this case should should we
be worried to invert a phrase often used
against Nazis first Twitter came for the
Nazis how long before they start coming
for regular run-of-the-mill
conservatives who violate their their
regulations and start criminalizing
thought even wondering if they're gonna
start coming after conservatives that
aren't violating the regulations and
they keep moving those regulations you
know we've seen other social media
platforms do this as well to fit with
the more politically correct narratives
listen I'm not a fan of Spencer I'm not
a fan of these other people that have
lost their checkmarks and eventually
their accounts but there is a level of
hypocrisy here and I'm kind of torn on
it because I don't know that a blue
checkmark is constitutionally protected
and there's a First Amendment and but it
isn't to promote it the blue checkmark
from Twitter doesn't mean that Twitter
agrees with every single tweet that Ben
Shapiro you or I send out it just means
yes this is Alicia Krauss this is her
verified account so anything else that
has like you know Alicia the crosses
eyebrows or something isn't going to
actually be myself so it's it's a
process of verifying that that's the
real person to prevent fraud not
necessarily to silent speech or promote
certain types of speech and and the
reason I'm torn on this is because
Twitter is a a private company and I
think that daily wire should be able to
do what they want Michael null should be
able to do it he wants and and part of
me does believe that Twitter as a
private company as a corporation should
be able to make the decisions that they
want well at least my notion you wanna
do what he wants I grew that decision
could potentially lead down the slippery
slope of conservatives eventually being
silenced sure though there is some case
at least for Facebook in YouTube that
they do have a virtual monopoly over
forms of information that's why Prager
right now is suing
them so I don't know I go back and forth
on this because I share many of your
misgivings about telling companies what
to do but that that distinction between
the checkmark initially was just to
identify that this is the real person
because there are a lot of fake accounts
you get these all the time you know
there's an account really funny account
been Shapiro's Yamaka you know or you
get all of these appear on 20/20 and you
get like there are a thousand fake Trump
accounts but the one with the checkmark
is how you know you're talking to the
real guy now though it's considered like
just a status symbol it's a mark that
I'm famous or I'm powerful or
influential or whatever there are people
who have that check mark who have like a
hundred followers but they're a just
they need the to know that it's a real
person because they've done something
that they're celebrity or they're not a
celebrity all but you know if like us in
this celebrity culture that's what it's
come to be it's a coveted status symbol
that blue checkmark who cares about it
who care what does Richard Spencer care
he gets to say what he wants people are
still following him if Twitter is going
to act childish as I think they are who
cares he still gets to spread his
ridiculous message anyway why why the
cult of celebrity that's a great
question and I actually just made it
through the Twitter purge myself I did
not lose my blue shirt all right maybe
not a Nazi yeah I think with this
situation with Richard Spencer it's just
Twitter trying to do everything they can
to not associate with him in any way so
I mean we're seeing it as well with
Taylor Swift a lot of people are coming
out now and saying hey Taylor Swift why
didn't you get political why are you
staying apolitical why haven't you taken
aside so I think it's kind of like the
leftist pressure on Twitter they they
don't want Twitter to give them a blue
check because you don't have to give
them a blue check and getting a blue
check means that Twitter went through
your profile and thought that you were
worthy so they don't want Twitter to
think Richard Spencer is worthy of
anything I think and that's why the
purge happened and you know a lot of
these people yeah they lose their blue
check mark they don't really care but I
think it does affect them in a bigger
way and it goes back to what I was
saying before it just feeds the echo
chamber that Twitter echo chamber now is
you know a little bit stronger and they
chipping away and eventually it'll be
just complete you know a complete
leftist mouthpiece the one advantage I
will say of the blue cheque is that as
someone who got a blue checkmark for
literally doing nothing for publishing
blank pages and selling a lot of books
the advantages that businesses when you
complain about them they give you stuff
so he's you know I had a flight that was
delayed like a thousand hours and was
all messed up and I complained about it
and they basically said what can we do
we'll do anything for you that's the
only advantage I also have to do with
the number of followers that you have I
mean this is something that I think Gary
Vee and and other people in
entertainment and marketing is stuff
I've talked about it's like you know is
it really a company having good customer
service if they're only answering to
their popular people that tweet hated
them you're right right doesn't matter
to me as long as I get the free stuff
but I just mean richard gets to say
whatever he wants his followers have
total access to whatever nonsense he
wants to scribble so you know what's the
big deal and and Bradley I do want to
talk about this a little bit because the
look I think Richard Spencer is
basically the devil but I do like that
he's honest I think a lot of people who
share his point of view they're not
honest they try to combine various
elements of conservative political
philosophy with this sort of quasi
fascistic racialist political view and I
respect him in that he doesn't do that
he is very clear he says the alt-right
is about white identity it's a we want a
white ethno state and so I at least give
him some credit for that he's had some
luck recently with a campaign that the
alt-right has run which is on college
campuses and it's a sign that says it's
okay to be white obviously a totally
innocuous statement and there they were
relying on the backlash for for
reasonable people to say well yeah
there's nothing wrong with that it's
okay to be white and obviously they're
their meta political goal here is to
have people start identifying
essentially or primarily with their skin
color rather than with something like
their ideas or their faith in God or
some other ideological component do you
do you find on campus that this is
catching on that people are falling for
this trap that the alt-right
are setting for them and that the
you left and the regressive left is
basically rolling out the red carpet for
people to do or is it falling flat oh
yeah I have several thoughts on the
alt-right and its campus presence but
first if there any young conservatives
watching watch Michael Knowles's video
on Prager University about the all right
it'll give you everything you need to
know about who they are and what they
believe in and if you're gonna be a Nazi
you might as well tell me straight to my
face even being a Nazi so I can punch
you in the face I'm joking I'm you're
gonna get you're gonna get unverified
for that you're gonna lose your
checkmark well actually a little aside
here young conservative writers that I
run in the same circles with are having
a very very difficult time getting
verified you're getting a blue checkmark
because you're verified that you have a
business I run a website called the
university of politics I'm their editor
in chief I still am struggling to get
verified so there's definitely
ideological censorship going on at
Twitter doesn't mean that you have a
right to have that blue checkmark I just
what the founders wanted me personally
if you're running a company and you're
borrowing half the population you know
forty seven percent of the population
voted for Donald Trump and you're
borrowing half of the population for
sharing their viewpoints and being a
verified individual you're going to lose
individuals on the website true further
than that yes the it's okay to be white
yeah poster yeah are they winning is
they alright winning on campus they're
not they're winning on the message
boards on 4chan and reddit because the
echo chamber within hyper liberal
campuses have pushed these individuals
down into this scummy
pepé meme society where they're
radicalized and it bubbles out in events
like Charlottesville so constitutional
conservatives needs to need to come out
very strongly against the alt-right and
tell individuals who don't necessarily
like political correctness that just
because the Left labels you all right
because you don't like political
correctness doesn't mean you are all
right you can come join the conservative
movement you can come be for individuals
right you can come B for lower taxes and
B for a strong national defense I'll go
further I'll go further I want the memes
I love the memes I think they're
hilarious I want Pepe Pepe is great I
just don't want the ethno State I don't
want people to ground their identity
essentially in race because I think
that's very stupid and it misses the
point of our creation and end of our
lives okay speaking of people who missed
the point of their life and speaking of
great evil and principalities and powers
of this world Charles Manson is on his
deathbed only 46 years after he was
sentenced to death tells you something
about criminal justice in the United
States so my first question Alicia on
the death penalty itself is it cruel and
unusual punishment to abolish the death
penalty
he's only still alive because it was
found unconstitutional in California for
some ridiculous reason in the 70s is it
is it wrong to abolish the death penalty
and lock people up for half a century
I think well I mean he would he would be
in hell of a sooner so I think that I'm
okay for the death penalty this is
something that I know that especially
some Catholic friends of mine say well
if you're gonna be pro-life then you
have to be pro-life throughout the whole
life but my argument is that a baby in
utero didn't murder people senselessly
and create a cult and lead people to do
disgusting and horrible things you know
Manson did do that as an adult and had a
fully formed functioning ability to
decide between right and wrong and child
in the womb does not and is at the whim
of the mother and the doctor you know
the abortionist so but I I think Manson
should have died a long time ago it
really pisses me off that my tax dollars
have been paying to keep him alive and
to hospitalized him and to feed him and
you know to have his crazy wife that he
married a couple years ago come and
visit him and tried to marry I think
that the license womper but yeah I guess
I guess it's harder to marry Charles
Mintz and then yeah yeah I mean that to
me is a very large red flag of our
criminal justice system understandably
there are some people that commit crimes
that lose their right to vote and people
are like oh but felons should have the
right to vote and I'm like no no like I
think you should lose everything when
you commit certain crimes
in this case I think Manson should have
lost his life a long time ago but it for
a little sympathy for Manson by the way
I will say on the Catholic point Pope
Pius the 9th Blessed Pope Pius the ninth
killed over 500 people he executed them
so you know there's some disagreement
among Catholics here certainly I think
so but a little sympathy for Manson the
guy had a horrible life his mother had
him when she was 16 well lots of people
out there that have had horrible life
that have not gone on the rampages that
he has been responsible it'll listen I'm
just trying to be so empathetic and
bleeding-heart here he you know his
mother didn't want him he was he didn't
have a name when he was born he was only
given a name a couple weeks later he was
abandoned by his mother initially he had
to live with an aunt or uncle or
something his parents went to prison he
never knew his actual father and he said
the only nice memory from his childhood
is the one hug his mother gave him after
she got out of jail he was completely
illiterate he didn't he was sent to a
boarding school because his mother tried
to give him away to the state the state
refused him he was sent to a boarding
school he ran away to his mother his
mother rejected him I mean this guy was
in prison for half of his life before
the chart the Manson Family
I mean it it's in some ways he never had
a shot from the beginning he was really
really a horrible tragic life that you
imagine for a little baby it was a
horrible tragic life you can't tell me
that there wasn't one decent person that
ever interacted with him and gave him
the opportunity to choose between right
and wrong he had multiple moments
throughout his life to do that but that
that is the question
you know flex does should we have any
compassion for this guy or should we be
happy that he's about to be sent to hell
I think if he wasn't a white male you'd
have a case there Michael forgot its
2017 yeah be on to something I don't
agree with you I don't think Charles
Manson was a great guy like you do it's
gonna be the taking null says Manson's a
great guy
we have talked about that later this guy
who murdered eleven people is really
cool or something that's what's gonna be
the headline he died sooner but you know
he also has a swastika tattooed to his
face so maybe if these protesters are
not working at all ever they should go
to the hospital and you know rally for
his death or whatever maybe that's
something that they would have you know
more fun doing than going to the ben
shapiro things point them in the
direction of a true nazi yeah
I would like to show just we have a
little clip of all the crazy things
Manson said not all of them but a
bridged version let's just show that to
get a picture of this guy kill anyone I
think when I stand on the mountain and I
say do it it gets done if it don't get
done then I'll move on it and that's the
last thing in the world you want me to
do I'm a boxcar nigella wine and a
straight razor you forget to close to me
it's Charlie Manson crazy or whatever
that means sure he's crazy as mad as a
hatter what difference does it make a
long time ago being crazy meant
something nowadays everybody's crazy
believe me if I started murdering people
there'd be none of your left you my
children are companies
I told you 20 years ago Charlie Manson
that you created That's not me you know
if I wanted to kill somebody I'd take
this book and beat you to death with it
and I wouldn't feel a thing it'd be just
like walking to the drugstore
terrifying guy obviously demonic really
scary stuff it's stuff you read about in
the Bible if you see it coming through
this guy so he's probably going to hell
but we can pray for his soul and and
maybe I'll have a last minute conversion
but I'm not terribly hopeful of that
panel thank you for being here we are
running a little bit of late so I have
to say goodbye to Bradley Devlin flex
and Alicia see you guys soon so I'm
gonna burn through these mailbag
questions I'm gonna change your life as
quickly as I ever have first question
from Stephen Michael what advice do you
have for someone wishing to start their
own business I hope these get through
the conversation I'm watching on my cell
phone thanks for watching and great
questions so we're always talking about
politics and government political
philosophy conservatives should be
starting businesses and doing things in
the real world my main advice is
register in Delaware
they have good they have good state tax
laws so register in Delaware get a
registered agent over there and you're
gonna fail you're gonna just fail and
fail and fail and try new things and but
do it that's the most important thing
everybody has great ideas and a great
business that they could start but very
few people raise the capital and go
through the personal risk and the hard
work of doing it starting a bit I've
started businesses businesses are very
difficult to start you don't get paid a
lot for a long time and then if it's
successful hopefully you will so a
persevere make sure you have a good
lawyer and an accountant so that you
paper work is very important and and
persevere because it's a real test of
you were of your character and what your
character has developed into to see if
you can actually put the pedal to the
metal and leave the field of abstraction
to exist in the real world from Matthew
question what is president Trump's
greatest flaw in your opinion you know I
had a lot of criticisms of Trump as a
candidate I've been very pleased by his
presidency he's been much better than I
expected he's been really good I think
he gets good grades for me but he's a
flawed guy just like anybody he might be
more flawed than some people and I love
the the thing that I think is his
greatest flaw partakes of one of the
great aspects of him which is his spirit
goodness he's he has ethos when he talks
when he gives a speech when he commands
a room you see that and I think we're
waiting for him to be Ronald Reagan we
really wish that he could give and a
time for choosing speech and articulate
these timeless principles from the Bible
up through Hayek and Burke and Kirk and
whatever and he doesn't demonstrate that
he hasn't been able to do that Andrew
Klavan says he's a plumber sometimes you
need a plumber to clear out your pipes
and sometimes you need an orator and
he's been really good at connecting
people and communicating and the you
know it I think if he were able to
exhibit that high morale truly inspiring
on a moral level the rhetoric I I think
he would be a force unlike which we've
seen certainly in my lifetime but all in
all he's been doing pretty good from
Murray hey there Michael
I've been trying to learn more about how
this country was founded in the balance
between natural rights and natural laws
it seems interesting to me that these
rights would be deemed inalienable or
unalienable when some could be taken
away or restricted by the same
government I can understand there are
limits because of natural law but why
then call them inalienable or
unalienable in the first place as
they're clearly not in some situations
are there any good books you could
recommend on the topic Thanks
so there I think people understand this
to say that a right is unalienable as
not to say that you're you you're right
cannot be violated it's to say that it's
a right that's absolute it's not a
contingent right it's it's not a right
that depends upon the the caprices of
political winds that depend on this
party being in power of that party my
the the right to control the border of
the United States might be dependent on
which party is in power at the time in
which parties running the government but
not my absolute right now you have
plenty of natural rights that are
violated all of the time you have a
right to life but the right to life is
constantly violated and which comes out
of the natural law which comes out of
God in Christianity so it's absolute it
means that you can right it's contingent
on a government you can go to a
government and
say look my right was violated and go
before that judge a right that's
absolute and not contingent on a
government but contingent on your
Creator you'll have to appeal to heaven
as this George Washington flag shows
you'll have to appeal to the ultimate
judge in heaven
next question from Jason little ol
Knowles yes little ol me
I was recently discussing spiritual
presence with a friend he was talking to
me about when he visited Germany and had
the opportunity to stand in one of the
crematoriums at a concentration camp we
questioned how men could stoop to such
evil as to systematically kill people
the way the Nazis did my conclusion was
that there are certain ideologies that
are at their foundation evil and people
could only become so evil by ensconcing
themselves in those ideologies would you
agree
and what ideologies do you think deserve
to be labeled as such I don't agree I
don't think people become evil simply
because of ideology someone had to
create the ideology right the ideology
had to come from somewhere I agree with
with what happens right after Noah gets
off the ark and he sacrifices to God and
God says God knew at that moment that
the imagination of man's heart was evil
from the beginning there were fallen
creatures and evil and here's an that
not simply in ideas but further evil has
a personality evil isn't just an
ideology it isn't just a set of ideas it
has a personality and has a name which
is Satan you see in first Peter quote be
sober be vigilant because your adversary
the devil as a roaring lion walketh
about seeking whom he may devour
in Ephesians put on your whole armor of
God that you may be able to stand
against the wiles of the devil
for we wrestle not against flesh and
blood but against principalities against
powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this world against spiritual
wickedness in high places the vents
enter as a then entered Satan into Judas
Iscariot being of the number of the
twelve the book of Job has God speaking
to the person of the devil
Jesus was led into the wilderness to be
tempted by the devil it has a
personality it is creeping along in the
world as we see in Paradise Lost as we
see in the Bible as we see in our own
metaphysical a vision of the world and
he's trying to get your soul so
I think when you view things that way
it's less clinical it's less secularized
it's less rationalist but it's it's much
more accurate and it will serve you
better to try to fight against evil from
Fitzgerald my girlfriend told me she's
bisexual what should I do
I always like straight women are you
lucky duck man that sounds great no I'm
kidding that's not I know it's very
fashionable these days
for women to say that they're bisexual
or men to say that their sexualities on
a spectrum and gender is on a spectrum
we see in all of the data show this that
among polling people are much less
likely now to say that they're straight
or cisgender that they are the gender
that they are I think that's a fad now
obviously there are people who are
attracted to both sexes and so your
girlfriend might be in that category I
don't know do you love your girlfriend
if you do stick with her if if that's a
breaking point then you know obviously
you guys should break up and I'm going
to withhold all of the other jokes that
I was thinking of when I saw your
question but I don't know man listen
this is these are not the worst problems
in the world you know okay next question
from Cedric hey Noel's king of trolls
Clavin makes fun of you all the time but
why do you never make fun of him a
simple answer he's the Supreme Lord of
the multiverse who could strike me down
whenever by just closing his eyes and
transporting me mystically into a Clavin
last weekend so I would I would never
tempt that power at all and I'm if
you're listening drew I'm sorry I even
read the question okay and from Theresa
hey Michael someone close to me straight
from the church years ago and is now
beginning to embrace the left they think
the stigma around socialism is
unwarranted they detest capitalism they
don't like organized religion sounds
like a great person it's almost
impossible to debate them because they
either get so heated or they pull the
moral relativism cord they just
basically ignore the conversation you
mean and say that there's no point to
talking because nothing is true or false
but heaven makes it so which is an
argument against its own argument I've
been trying to get them to at least
consider going back to church they
refuse is there anything I could do to
help them embrace a less destructive
world view yeah so the term capitalism
we use we defend capitalism we know what
we mean by capitalism
the term is an invention of socialists
and communists it's not like this term
has been around for thousands of years
it was coined in the 19th century by
french socialist politician lui Blanc
he used it first Marx and Engels used it
soon thereafter in volume 1 of der copy
Tao the idea of capital comes from the
cell 12th century of the idea referring
to funds and stock of merchandise and
money and money that carries interest
and so forth but it's freedom talk about
it in terms that don't use the isms that
the Communists and the other ideologue
is trying to foist on us talk about it
as a matter of freedom do you think
people should be able to use the money
how they want and hire who they want and
do you think the people should be able
to work for whom they want to work and
negotiate contracts and deal in free
markets that are protected by laws if
you like that then that's pretty good as
far as going back to the church if this
person is using relativistic arguments
it's very simple to stop those arguments
they say well you know that's your
opinion man but don't forget opinions or
not preferences their statements of fact
as you see them so a preference is I
really like this cough FA a an opinion
is this is the greatest cough FA in the
world one is a statement of fact another
statement of fact would be I I think
this is the greatest gift FA in the
world or this is the greatest graph FA
in the world right so the way to stop
the relativist so-called argument is to
say if they say truth doesn't exist then
you say well that's impossible because
for you to stage the truth doesn't exist
requires there to be a truth that is
truth doesn't exist which doesn't so if
you can communicate the point the
communication breaks down because of
relativistic nonsense you might be able
to crack her this intellectual fad that
she seems to be going through which has
no bearing to reality ok I think we
sprinted through that that's our whole
show heading into the Clavin List we can
listen to another kingdom by Andrew
Clavin and performed by me it's
everywhere great podcasts are downloaded
stitcher Google Play and iTunes and I
will see you next week folks on Michael
Noel's this is the Michael Noel's show
try to survive the weekend
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
marshal Benson executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex is and
Garo audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jesuit all Vera
and our Associate Producer is Bailey
Lynn the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for word publishing 2017